yes I'm the speaker uh my name is Alan
Wong on the topic it will be a
topological optimal internet and my co
speaker is Scott Knauer we're both of
veterans or survivors of e3 80 oh and I
want to tell you how tough it was in the
old days we show up and put our
signature or leave someone had to put
our signature on a list and so ah well
thank you for inviting me and from the
title if you folks are expecting a
theoretical talk of sort of mathematics
on topology I'm sorry you're going to be
disappointed instead i'm going to show
you an optimal internet and how to get
there via ebay and PGP all right here's
the basically the the original
telecommunications infrastructure it's
circuit switched it was laid out by
following rivers following the migration
of Buffalo following rail railways a
sexual and then it's been optimized many
times by linear programming uh yeah I'm
sorry you know those are Mormons you
know okay so um up her okay so what
happened is what they've done here is
they've optimized what was left over
from the cattle runs and so forth to
minimize the total length of copper okay
on all the paths um there's this other
type of network called a packet network
which in the old days people really
worried about how many hops you were
away from you know the next node or
something like that and so it had a
whole different constraint or you know
optimization thing the trouble was that
people superimposed the internet on top
of the telecommunications in the
structure and so what happens is you
have a now a sort of an Internet that
has been optimized go then
what should be designed to minimize the
number of hops rather than the total
path length okay you say okay great
observation you know obvious up what are
you going to do about it you know it's
like the weather first of all tell you
why the number of hops matters because
every time when you hop every time when
you touch a packet you incur a latency
because of buffering because of
processing and because of routing all
right and this translates not only the
latency it translates into power it
translates into cost and so the fewer
hops you get the the better off you are
all right okay how can you reduce the
number of hops the first thing you can
do is make the flat system into a toroid
okay you can just put all these links in
and then what because it's a toroid you
can reduce the number of hops by a
factor of two right off the bat okay but
you're thinking god this is impractical
who's going to lay all this fiber and
it's going to cost a fortune and such
like that who's going to do this well it
turns out that you can basically
repurpose the existing links to do the
toroid I'll show you all right the first
step is assume that you add enough
toroidal connections to support half
your current traffic all right and what
you've done there is half the traffic
moves on to the toroidal connections and
half of the capacity of the original
network will not be used so then all you
have to do is move all the traffic from
the toroidal connections back on to the
original internet with no net increase
in bandwidth all right and so what I've
shown here at the bottom ah the the
first let's say the the northmost
toroidal connection goes from Seattle to
Boston I showed as blue green and then
yellow the one from San Francisco to New
York goes a red sort of magenta and then
purple and the other one goes the other
way and so basically I you have the
connectivity there you have the
bandwidth there you just have to
repurpose it
okay next thing i want to show you
there's something weird here okay how
are you going to actually implement this
all right what you do is that every node
you bypass it so normally nodes have
these wavelength division multiplexing
coming in on the fibers and they have a
router in the center all I'm talking
about is you take the electronic output
of one of the wavelengths that are
coming in and you connect it with a
patch cord to one of the outputs going
out and you just leave it there that's a
bypass and there's funny things that
when you do this okay it's going to cost
you one extra patch cord but when you do
this you spare up a you spare up a
router port okay well okay usually
they're bidirectional all right and so
what happens is this means you could
basically sell that on eBay after you do
this and so what he means is when you
have the number of hops you can have the
number hops while eliminating half the
router ports this is literally less is
more it's one of those strange
situations that if you get rid of half
your hardware you become more efficient
okay this was you can okay next thing is
some of the nodes are a little different
some of the nodes are on rings as you
can see in this network there is made up
of a lot of rings when you're on a ring
you're usually connected to the optical
ring by something called a
reconfigurable optical add drop
multiplexer or Rotom and so all you have
to do is reset the road and reconfigure
the modem so you never have to drown to
drop down to base level okay you have
never have to go from optics electronics
and so this relieves eliminates the need
for one transceiver optical transceiver
port as well as a router port okay so
you can put more stuff on eBay okay this
thing this is a very dated a map of the
internet it's having to do with NSF
backbone in December 94 and what you see
is the actual t3 connections but you'll
see in the other colors though where the
actual destination is
and you could see that a toroidal
connections would really get rid of a
lot of the crap that's going through the
middle of the country all right and so
and the crap that's going to the middle
of the country's it sort of like stops
at each one of the nodes in between
that's the problem if I'm going to snake
the bandwidth through you know on some
of the available bandwidth and I bypass
it it means i free up all the
intermediate times i have to touch the
packet in between alright so now the
question becomes can you reduce the
number of hops further when you look at
this network the basic network you say
okay this is kind of funny in that it's
really flat there's only one place where
it sort of violates you know flatness
and it turns out that you can reduce the
number have hops by also using a higher
dimension topology such as a hypercube
all right so here's an example I mean
we've all gone through school we've had
a teacher talk about okay and one
dimensions you put n nodes is this long
if you put into two mentions they get
closer by the square root if you put in
three dimensions it gets closer by the
cube root and if you put in a fourth
dimension you know it gets closer by the
fourth root so the way to make a cube
based network is you basically construct
a cube you assign a city to each one of
the cubes or the routers and then you
pancake it all right through into two
dimensions and then you rubberband all
the routers to where they're really
geographically located and you'll get
this squirrely looking network that's
flat or sort of a sort of like spin
pancake but is now more efficient
because everything is closer together
because it's a cube network and the
other interesting point about this
you're not going to ever get here this
is one of those one-way functions you're
ever never going to find this very
strange connections if you decided to
just incrementally improve what was laid
out by cows okay if they don't think
that way all right so this is one way of
doing a cube
and then you go go in the fourth
dimension or the fifth dimension and you
get diminishing returns but i'll show
you that later there's an even better
approach and that's called multi-stage
switching networks in the 80s there were
big Wars here there was the Banyan
Network the butterflied network in the
shuffle network and the Banyan network
these are all log base two of n networks
or log n networks because if your fan
out as higher it becomes log the base of
n so you can even cross it squash it
further you might notice that in the
first part this one is sort of like you
can see that the routing algorithm is
basically powers of two you know the
first but you can go in here next bit
next bit nets but this is a little screw
you these turns out to be isomorphic Lee
the same uh this one's a little
different breed it comes from something
else what the difference is that this is
is that they scale differently this
scales by doubling the skills by
doubling and this scales by the next
largest prime because it's based on
group theory but you can sort of subvert
that by putting a twist in it so that
something i call Galois networks so you
can grow even by the composite the neck
composite as well as the next prime
number so you can really cut down the
number of hops by using multistage
networks and this shows you the benefits
of various networks in other words I've
taken out all the ceiling functions
because they just screw up everything
there's the you know the a square
Network a cube network etc higher
dimensions you get better um down here
are all the the multistage networks they
barely break in of two hops all right
here's what a multi-stage based network
would look like that's also a toroid um
if you look at this you'll see I put a
router associate of each city I these
are basically 8-port routers I use two
ports for the local drop and I use the
other six to sort of like connect to the
overall the outside fabric
and I have basically just rubber band
them to the particular location I
connect them together in a toroid but
what you'll notice is there are at most
two hops between any two nodes so from
any city to any other city you can get
there in two hops or less okay I I sort
of a actually show this suppose in green
you wanted to go from seattle to
washington DC you would do these
connections shown in green if you wanted
to go from LA to Boston then you would
do all the purple connections it turns
out to be just one connection if you
want you to go from denver to miami you
would go from here all the way around
you're basically toroidal connection
back up to denver okay how can you
actually implement these things you know
i mean you're going to have these
strange connections you know like
spaghetti all across the united states
and what happens is you don't have to
add new links you don't have to really
do anything all you have to do is
reconnect the WDM channels at each one
of the nodes you have many different
colors coming and usually it's like 30
two different colors on each fiber and
uh you all I have to do now is just
connect various colors together in
different ways and I can construct any
geometry I want and so the key point
here is with WDM you can decouple the
topology of the network from
geographical constraints okay and so
this means you can build any any network
you fantasize just by redoing those
connections not on the fly this is
dynamic you just sort of like reconnect
them all right here's example I showed
the router for Chicago I show from
Chicago were these these routes actually
go I forgot to insert of include the
toroidal collection connections but if
you look at it there's one connection to
Washington DC and that's shown here
there is a one connection by green all
the way to LA and there's all the
connections up to Seattle etc runs a San
Francisco and to remember that every
time I bass bypass a node I spare a
router point port or in a past and
possibly a transceiver card and so you
have to do this for all these other
nodes it's a little complicated but i'll
show you later on what the wrote were
for doing this is uh this is a bit of an
aside when you're doing all this I it
turns out I I added an extra row here
for fault tolerance of routers all right
and it's because when you do a
multi-stage network and I keep it log n
levels I have no redundancy and that's
dangerous so by adding an extra level I
can basically multiply the amount of
redundancy in this case I added and that
increases by a factor of 6 so now i have
a fault tolerance of 6 so in between all
the nodes are six it down or six
connections and that's in a tremendous
amount of redundancy all right and it
turns out that this extra redundancy has
another advantage it increases voice and
video throughput bye-bye basically
decreasing something called fabric
blocking all right it sort of opens up
the throat or the width of the network
that you're connecting any place to
anyplace else and this is going to
become more and more important because
the internet traffic is becoming more
isochronous in other words more like a
more like circuits and fabric blocking
becomes more and more of an issue all
right how much is this cost you know you
added a whole layer of extra routers
first thing I'd like to point out which
is kind of funny is like where did which
is the real extra layer they're all
doing work here each one's assigned to a
city so which one's the extra layer it
ends up that every layer acts as the
extra layer for the other layers because
it's a cycle and so that I thought that
was really cute
second of all all the things are doing
work all right and so usually when you
learn about fault tolerance in college
and stuff line w classes you say oh
there is duplex you have our tandem you
have two things but one of the systems
is just sitting there doing nothing and
then you have majority vote you have
three systems and basically two systems
are just there to check you know each
other so there's all this extra activity
going on in this case where's the extra
hardware where's the you know where's
the extra what's sitting idle everything
is working okay so you're getting and
then you say okay Alan it's because that
extra layer if you sort of view this as
like an accordion I could have done it
instead of a 3 by 4 matrix I could have
done as a a 4 by 3 matrix if I put four
of them in a row and then three rows I
would have had no redundancy so what I'm
buying the redundancy is by squeezing it
in changing the aspect ratio when I
change the aspect ratio and I basically
add a half a hop and so the extra fault
tolerance and the redundancy and the
less fabric blocking is coming from that
one half a hop okay you said Alan
something's got to give here you know
you can't get all this for nothing um
how much is the average packet length
increase and I don't want to bore you if
all going through this algebra but what
happens if you assume the United States
has a width of W and a length of L and
you sort of apply that to the same type
of routing that I showed you but I
flipped it on the side you can work out
the whole differences in the average
path in their words maximum path / half
and such a lie you'll see that you're
paying an additional armed with divided
a foot by 4 in other words a quarter of
the width United States is how much you
might have to average packet might have
to travel and since the with you and I
taste is probably 120 miles a hundred
1,200 miles you're talking about 300
miles okay it ends up ok what's 300
miles ok if l equals about 3,000 miles w
goes to 1200 and the speed of light
equals this it turns out the difference
is equal to 300 miles it turns out this
is a fourteen percent increase in the
average path length and it turns out
this is equivalent to two point four
milliseconds in travel time ok the speed
of light is pretty fast even within a
glass ok the benefits are what I did
here is I did basically a ratio of the
old average path length versus the new
path length all right and basically I
can show the old path length here that
the maximum path length becomes like six
hops and the average would be divided by
half and so that's three hops and in my
other technique I showed you that the
maximum path length through the the
multistage network is basically two hops
and so the average must be one hop and
so you get a ratio here of three hops
it's a factor of three less hops and for
this network over here if I did that
same calculation it would be a factor of
4.5 less hops right and what does this
mean this means in this case it's three
times less latency less power and less
cost and here it means 4.5 factor of 4.5
less latency less power and less cost ok
and as he said you could sell all the
extra you know an eBay all right you say
ok Alan this might have been good you
know 20 years or 30 years ago and uh but
now everything's got really complicated
we have all these policies we have all
this you know the whole OSI stack and
everything like that and people have put
all these protocols on top it ends up
what I'm doing is really below or sort
of at the physical level the rest of the
stack doesn't care it has no clue of
anything geographic
other than hops hops PGP was the border
gateway protocol comes in at the the
sixth level or seventh level and that's
where the tables get exchanged and it
gets used at different places but the
whole rest of the stack just views the
whole world as how many hops okay this
as a cynical comment here it means that
no standards committees need to be
involved okay yes cost of what yeah how
much does it cost in terms of what I you
know that depends if you just do a ping
I the cost of hops that was in the
previous slide let's see is two point
four milliseconds that's the average
added to the travel time because that's
the hole for a whole path but we saved
three hops at least okay are you / 3
mops costs if you chop cause for example
one min sick and then this one maybe
it's not too much benefits but Holocaust
presented four minutes again then yes we
have tuna stopped he's richer than I
need to bite into 2014 yes 2.4
milliseconds is for the complete half
complete average path I didn't say okay
this is just travel time it does not
include anything having to do how long
you sit at router so if you see how much
time you said it router your you know no
it's hard
all right I have to go through border
gateway protocol because some people
might not know what that means when you
sort of like add a router to the network
and you wake it up the first thing it
does is like it doesn't know where it is
and stuff like that so it asks the
neighboring routers hey give me your
routing table what's the routing table
that you have and so it gathers all the
routing tables and synthesizes its own
routing table and figures out what's the
best way to get to New York what's the
best way to go to Chicago what's the
best way to go Los Angeles and sometimes
they're duplicates and when they're
duplicates what people do is they
basically do Rob Robin among all the
equivalent paths what I'm suggesting is
basically you hash on the lowest part of
the the source address and this program
this makes all the packets that came
from the same thing go to the same up
half okay that's just a little
refinement but what my point here about
border gate a border gateway protocol is
PGP is essentially a distributed
gradient descent algorithm it's going to
find the shortest path ok because it's
or like the lowest energy all right and
so the way to implement this is if you
see the network with an optimal
multistage solution then PGP will
automatically discover the solution and
start to wrecking traffic onto the
optimal network okay so if you just even
put like toroidal connections there
you'll see that p-gp will say hey that's
a shortcut I'm going to take the
shortcut and it's going to move
everything up to the shortcut okay and
it's going to saturate the shortcut and
then what you have to do is add more
connections we build that shortcut and
make it stronger and you just keep on
doing this until there's really you know
no real significant increase so that's
one thing the second thing is the non
seeded links are thus suboptimal so they
can be cannibalized to strengthen
the seeded network all right so I
thought of analogy of this it's like in
Los Angeles if you assume the highway
system is optimally spaced okay and here
you are you sort of like a human GPO
beep hbu no border gateway protocol
algorithm and you say okay I'm going to
take the freeway because it's the
fastest way to get there and all of a
sudden you find out that everyone else
just uses that same algorithm and so it
gets clogged what you should do then is
basically cannibalize all the roads
other roads and side roads and build
more lanes to the highway and you just
keep on extending this and then it'll
become just like the songs you know la
is just one endless freeway you know and
but this works for packets it might not
work for LA all right I wanted to end up
the last thing about Network Zen um the
last line here I've shown that topoli
topologically optimal networks exist
okay there's a whole family of them you
can sort of like start your from any
particular thing it'd be a banyan a
butterfly shuffle or something like that
that's really not the point well I guess
it is the point that it exists all right
what happens is that the journey towards
the goal is probably even more important
and so once you sort of like string one
of these things are even trying to build
towards one of these toroidal
connections you'll see that you'll
gradually improve you'll reduce the load
on everything else and you improve the
internet traffic and so I'm saying that
the pgp sort of algorithm trying to push
it in that way is better than just
incremental e increasing as I said cow
paths from the 1800s okay if I wasn't
ranting before I'm gonna rant now all
right um you'll notice I've carefully
removed logos on various things you know
I hope I have okay one carrier got find
one hundred million dollars by the FCC
for throttling their unlimited bandwidth
customers they basically oversold their
bandwidth
and now they're going to cry at the FCC
and say oh we could help it you know it
the door the traffic overwhelmed us in
our mill are you know there's nothing we
could do well i'm showing you there's
something you can do alright another
carrier wanted to abolish network
neutrality because the netflix was
causing their network to quote meltdown
and it's like if you look at your
network it's a it's a milk run it was
sort of put together by mergers and
acquisition lawyers you know it's like
you give us a break you know in other
words and i actually wrote at FCC about
this but i didn't get any reply but it
was like yes i know it's too many levels
there for them to comprehend i I ok this
inspired a joke or so how many lawyers
does it take to fix in network there
trouble ifs I tried to deal with the FCC
and with these various carriers or
something like that I run into lawyers
there no more engineers anymore its
marketing people and lawyers and they
are bit challenged in terms of the math
okay and the optics all right so let me
now go on the rant about math all right
um when I start talking about those
usually I try to build up to it and go
through the multi-dimensional networks
and I've noticed this phenomenon when
I'm talking that okay they sort of like
or listening until I hit the third
dimension but then when I go to the
fourth dimension I can feel them sort of
like wanting to move away although you
know psychologically put a little
distance I can also feel that they are
sort of looking on my lapel to see if
I'm wearing a Star Trek emblem okay and
no i'm not you know or our little flag
there either but then what happens is
they start looking around the room to
see if someone's filling them on you
know for youtube or something like that
they're going to post it you know on
facebook and so it's a really
if if the math teacher didn't expose
them to this in the high school they're
never going to get it the more you talk
about it it's hopeless and another thing
I will tell you don't even try starting
to try to explain group theory you know
I tried diverting and trying to talk
about Rubik's cubes and how it relates
to group theory and then perfect
shuffles and how really card tricks and
they get lost they I can never bring the
conversation back they just sort of like
want to know about the card trick you
know I I remember showing see you this
is a long time ago something is similar
to this and he got fascinated with the
with the perfect shuffle wanted me to
show him again so he can impress some
chick in a bar someday you know it was
like give me a moment back back to
optics ok sorry ok optics is another
problem what I got all these people sort
of telling me about well optics doesn't
work this way you know and you know you
can't do that you can't it's because
they really don't understand the optics
the other thing is what I find kind of
cute about this idea you're not going to
get here unless you understand math
networking and optics in other words
you're going to run into a barrier you
need all three to realize you know if
you only know two of the three it's
still not good enough and you know other
people if you didn't realize that you
can decouple the topology of the network
from from a geographical constraints you
would think that all the stuff was just
ridiculous talking about higher space
stuff that you know oh you can have to
lay fiber all the place you know and
everything is get evil last thing I
there was a very famous book called
flatland and the romance of multiple
dimensions and um they make this whole
joke about how certain you know
two-dimensional things can't understand
what's going on in three dimensions of
such like but it's clear we're all stuck
in flatland here and there's no reason
to you know this is just now every time
when you you see you know this thing
you're just going to scream flatland you
know so summarize here it's a number of
hops matters
ok that's the criterion second thing is
the higher dimensions and groups will
get you there faster all right last the
next point WDM decouples the network
topology from geographical constraints
all right you can build any crazy
Network you there and you just have to
reset some settings you don't know the
last one is networks then just working
towards this is aa towards this goal is
significant improvement over the current
internet all right and I made a load
joke here note the toroid all right a
history here because this is a Stanford
connection um how did this all begin it
began uh when Scott and I basically went
to Bell Labs and the first thing we did
was this switch it was the world's
fastest packet switch in the early 1980s
it could handle 32 inputs each other 100
megabits and it's basically made out a
lot of sorting networks and multistage
networks here Oh cetera this is a TTL
version it's it consumed I think 12
kilowatt and it was I reduced it down to
a chip right shown here and so the chip
basically didn't work as fast but it was
the equivalent to all the hardware what
the point here was that this would went
into sort of like we tried to build a
natural ATM switch out of it later on
the technology but this part of it Scott
and I were sitting in this room watch
you know running some tests on this
thing and sort of warming ourselves in
the winter you know next to the the we
called it the brass elephant and we
started having delusions of grandeur and
the first thing was like oh here we got
it all on a chip and we can get it
between boards we can get it between
shells we can get it between
racks we can build these multistage
networks to cover you know across a
whole of city to all the central offices
we can hook together a ladder we can
hook together you know arnar barbell
regional operating company to get this
and we can take over the world of these
multistage networks so we thought it was
such a great idea so we approached our
management and in less than a month they
classified it as proprietary and we
weren't allowed to even talk about it
within bell labs or write about it okay
it just we snuck it in or put it into
some patents like you know we're
variously and it's gotten lost there I
tried to resurrect it you know after the
patents expired and tried to build using
some of this technology a terabit router
but that didn't go anywhere then it
turned out I was sitting at a conference
sponsored by ntt about five years ago
and I saw because of all their disaster
you know they had this so Sami and other
things earthquake I thought they really
should do the full tolerance this this
is a great way for doing network fault
tolerance and so I resurrect there and
then just I embellished it and then just
recently I started working out the cost
and then I realized that hey you know of
ebay you know we can get there okay this
is a little more the Stanford connection
since we built this essentially one year
after Stanford you can sort of like do
pointers or reverse trace here in terms
of where all the ideas came from Harold
stone was Scott's adviser he had the
perfect shuffle I took courses from
Donald Knuth about searching sorting and
searching and the discrete math Mike
Flynn I dick took computer architecture
from Al in conway from was at xerox parc
and she did a vlsi class I took a class
by this crazy person talking about the
internet called Vince cert and then Joe
Goodman
was my advisor and I learned optics for
them and then the bell labs connection
was a Chuck Rutledge he and scott
basically build a TTL or the gate array
version jo Neal and I did the chip
humming Lou followed later on after at
Bell Labs he was at bell house but he
followed on doing the default tolerance
and the new Galois fields networks and
these two guys were managers who
basically put up with us so some history
there when Scott and I got to Bell Labs
it was basically I think bella's was
beginning to suspect that it might be
the end of circuit switching and we
helped try to push that or get the point
across that basically you can't get
there from here and these were some
examples of this is the future you know
here's the future television looks like
down here here's what the future of your
telephone booth is going to look like
and your regular telephone is going to
start looking like an Etzel what we
didn't realize was this telephone booth
is going to become your mobile phone
your smart phone so it's going to even
go further but that was the limits of
our imagination at that time this was a
that Scott had this he covered his wall
at murray hill with all these cartoons
all these other things but this is my
favorite and everything seemed normal if
you don't let you look close and if you
look close right there you'll see why it
was a joke all right all right um this
is scott Knauer and most probably a good
percentage of the talks that we would
give he would be dressed up as Darth
Vader complete with a mask and heavy
breathing on the side and just mocking
me at every time he could uh you had an
attachment
the pinhead I don't understand why and I
just wanted to say he was sort of like
true to Stanford um you might say he was
an arbiter of the limits of good taste
and he he the reason why I gave had
talks is he never found the pun that he
didn't like and it was excruciating on
the audience you know they just can't
take it you know he's just like he also
had this very strange capability of
writing a ridiculous song lyrics or long
5900 line poems in iambic pentameter you
know it's like what a strange mind the
reason I mention him is a few things
well he died he's not here ah best thing
i can say as he died proving his faith
um the reason why i mention it here he's
he's done something very significant
that has touched all our lives but we
don't know about it okay and i'm here to
sort of tell you right from the
beginning he was really into television
and this is his version of 3d television
this is Arno Penzias our Vice President
and Nobel Prize winner he worked at NASA
Ames on cosine transforms cosine trick
compression and then he went at when he
was at Stanford Hugh did his thesis on
cosine compression transforms and when
yet bail after he worked on the packet
switching stuff with me he went off to
do the digital television stuff the new
standard stuff for digital television
and a lot of his ideas never succeeded
but what he ended up doing was he ended
up doing the circuit that is in the
innermost loop and your HD television
and happens to be a discrete cosine
transform or something similar to a
cosine discrete for what he did this is
a rule nerdy thing I would explain you a
cosine transform is basically a vector
matrix multiply what he did was he took
the thick
coefficients of the matrix and divided
into a upper bite and in a lower bite
matrix and then he noticed that a lot of
the multiplications were the same so he
factored out all the identical
multiplications small multiplications
and then on top of that he diddled with
some of the coefficients so that they
were balanced but they still uh so he
could build more of these sort of like
factored out some multiplies and then he
mo did the multiplies in an ordinary
manner like a wolf of Wall Street with a
lot of full adders taking out the zero
multipliers and then he put it on a VLSI
chip but what he did was he put it into
a grid thing and then used the
compression algorithm and compressed
both dimensions into a square and when
he wasn't satisfied he would move sum of
the squares around to see if you
compress more he disses like a couple of
dozen times you know crunching through
computers and when he showed me this
thing the best way to describe it it
looked like someone had steam rolled
over the board or cube okay you know it
was had so much complexity of these
wires going in place and my first
comment is we should leak this to the
Japanese he'll put them back five years
okay but it was incredibly compact and
incredibly fast and that became an i
triple e standard and as a result it's
in every one of your televisions okay
and so this is his tribute and I wanted
to tell you I started off wanting to
give you a different way of viewing the
internet and this is my suggested now
new model for the internet what happens
is a perfect shuffle is really a dual
helix counter clockwise and the counter
clockwise helix but they've been
squashed flat so that's the perfect
shuffle okay so if you make a toroidal
connection out of it what you get is a
donut and so on top of this donut you
see that okay the stars would represent
little routers and the little sprinkles
here would be like bill w dem
connections and so this is what I want
you to think about about
future internet okay thank you very much
for your time so any question yes having
optimize the way the number of hops yes
you want to now start thinking about
Linc Linc total Kathleen you can't do
both do one of the other so what happens
is I'm saying they optimized for the
wrong thing and I'm going to the other
extreme and I think this is a better
match to the Internet in general you can
do this on your local network you can do
it within Stanford you could do it with
it make it into a torrid that you get
the most bang for your buck there and
it's the easiest to explain and you can
incur mentally show that you're getting
benefit because it unloads the rest of
your network okay so literally you able
to that's the trade-off any other
questions Monica um can you get there
from here without having a bad day
without getting a what can you get from
here without having a bad day when
everybody switches at once can you oh no
you can do incremental e that's what I
was trying to do the network Zen
anything helps it's a smooth function
and so what happens is anything along
direction right now we're not moving
anywhere because we're just recreating
what's there and so if you see anything
anything that works towards a throttle
connection any any routers you can put
on your port you can sort of like
surplus or bypass you know that will
help make it more efficient yes the big
deal is to get the background carriers
to implement the bypass links at major
points yes and sort of that that brings
to mind the 522 and 22 buses on el
camino you know that the Express mess
doesn't stop at all the stops yes and
this goes a lot faster this is why
trollin connections are a lot easier to
explain because people can see this was
an express lane it's sort of like fine
the harder concept for people to
understand believe it or not is the
Detroits i watched people at the newark
airport you know they had this bus are
let off on the parking lot and people
all crowd
right at the beginning they don't
understand you know you could park
anywhere it's gonna be the same time
around the thing or something like that
and so there are a lot of situations
where it seems obvious retrospectively
like I just can't see how people can't
see the toroid I just it's my
frustration so this is really a
psychological when this talk is
psychological therapy for me yeah well I
is the incremental you get some of the
benefits I just at each city just do the
bike that's fine yes when y'all doing
any work at all and I do you know you
never say to all right cuz once you say
if I skip one city what happens if i
skip to this is like a drug addict you
know like it and then you'll say but the
trouble is you can't monitor the
decreased traffic because you're really
unloading the rest of the network when
you do this and a lot of this thing is
everyone's sort of working their own
spreadsheet and trying to optimize for
themselves and they're screwing the
whole you know it's like you know if
someone just does this then everyone
benefits it's it's you know yes does
this work in a data center as well as
the internet yes ah i think i've gained
some countries i think if you look at
all the data centers like the facebook
data center on to google or if they
don't do it now hi when it hits youtube
they're gonna do it it's a stupid okay
what happened is you have to use
Internet routing you have to use an IP
run you can't use an ethernet routing
then it gets confused going around okay
but your facebooks is done with an IP
and i think most of the modern data
centers are doing a full IP route
because then they can link it directly
to other IP you know other data centers
in the same namespace okay and so it
makes it a cleaner when you start
thinking multiple data centers together
so this works for data centers this
works for I it you get the best bang for
your buck going toroid in the other car
yeah
yes yeah so bgp also has an economic
component to the routing decisions not
purely descent yes so how does that
affect this okay this gets long not own
Darrell the cost it has to do if also
policies a lot of the policies are meant
because in the old days there were these
long thin networks like you had to go to
you know foreign land and they didn't
want you to go anyplace else or
something like that and those things are
still stuck there okay but they kind of
disappear when there's only two hops I
mean half the hops are basically one hop
away example where Los Angeles and three
options yes that their descent of the
fewest Hobbs yes based on economic
considerations I might make more money
by using more hops Oh contracts in place
that's the trouble yeah you know and so
it is that's where I think the toroid is
the best because uh you're going to a
bypass situation and there's no policy
no PGP you know and I hadn't thought
about it that's a sly way of getting
around PGP you know he's like Oh what
packets there's this thing that they
used to grade a lot of the current
internet on there called bypass packets
a lot of packets just go through the
router and they really didn't have to be
touched okay I mean it's like this is a
waste of everyone's time you know and or
every package time and so this way of
doing this thing you'll see that you'll
eliminate bypass packets entirely which
you go to optimal because you only go to
where you have to make a decision yeah
that's it all right that's why I say
it's optimal any other questions okay
bypassing the router plugging it back in
the other side yeah that sort of assumes
that I've got multiple connections from
point A to point B otherwise I don't
know I mean ah basically you're just the
the vibra comes in on one thing with
multiple channels and fiber goes out and
another fiber goes out here and so I'm
doing a psycho taking here and going
straight out from the fiber I don't go
through the router at all the wrap the
router has basically yeah an input port
in an output port but they're both on
the same card I've got a box in Boston
sending packets and they get to New York
and they want to go to Philadelphia yeah
okay and some of them will I go to
Philadelphia other ones want to go to
New York yes so I'm saying that you you
can bypass the places where you don't
have to make a decision okay I'm just
network you'll see that your there's
another way the thing could have gone to
get to Philadelphia we can talk about
this on offline okay yes the less time
you hit a router probably the better
because our people can walk with routers
you know I think there's a low level
when you're staying at the physical
level of just optical fiber this fault
tolerance is also a little more secure
because there's so many other ways to
get there so someone blows up you know
two of the links or something or cuts
two links I this one is safer and other
ways you so I think its face safer
physically for physical damage
software-wise I um can i phrase this all
right having design Lord switches that
at it's very easy to put a kill switch
into chips that no one can find and ah
then just have a certain
sequence and you can so I there's a
reason why people shootin by routers
from a company that can't ensure the
food chain all the way through alright
and that's why there are certain
restrictions on what companies you can
buy from so the you can avoid some of
these trick shins you know you always
worried that someone's going to put one
stupid thing in there and so by keeping
it at the optical level you know all
optical level the more you're reducing
that that's saying I think any other
questions that economic so it appears
it's there's there's various reasons why
people want to either not go into
somebody's network or Dougal into some
artists throat let's throw traffic you
don't care about off your network on to
somebody else's even if you're hosing
the traffic yeah and it's unclear how
this plays with that and also with the
other questions why restrict this to the
United States because the unite the
world has a nice property is yes forward
okay a few things the ones I talked
about that carrier within a carrier they
don't have some of the debates that you
have what they shouldn't you know 18t
you stupid you know the lattice or the
regional our box used to but so that's
sort of like the they have to argue
among themselves you know and if they
can't get the accounting right because a
lot of that's just accounting it's like
okay yeah or their costs things but I'm
saying that uh it's not obvious that
cost structures now all right any other
questions
so you're justifying Steve Jobs donut
and cupertino's what you're saying I
didn't know that Steve Jobs don't a
spaceship oh yeah and also JD how you
put a great networking there you know
numbers a that's how they should
organize in there exactly we should all
know what and also GCHQ which is a donut
in England too okay fine I've got to
customers that took and repeat Republic
yes yes ring ring this is nothing this
is you know um i wish i came up with all
this before but it's sort of like how
come you don't think big enough scale
okay this is just bigger I think big
there's a repro the Rantisi remember
beltway's yeah but it turns out the same
reason well all fibers are deployed as
rings okay because it's just easier you
just dig one hole you know all the way
around and then they so there are a lot
of rings around traffic signals yeah
okay clusters are architected you find
there are a couple of standards network
topologies the beers and tore it is one
of them battery is another yeah and
hyper cube is another and depending on
what they're doing any one of those can
be optimal for them but dr. right is
probably the most common yes you have
fun this is a pet peeve of mine I showed
that graph the hypercube st. got it ok
they peter out all right and there are a
lot of hassle ah the the factory is sort
of a cheat okay it is it just gets
fatter and fatter if they showed it in
three dimensions you know in terms of
the bandwidth ah and it doesn't scale
dot great alright and so are you get the
bat most bang for the buck toroid melt
well okay thank you
you